[Música]
bienvenidos a cultura versión casa por
la pandemia este marzo tal vez lo
recordarán un collage del artista
digital people hizo historia al
subastarse en christie's por 69 millones
de dólares más allá de estar la tercera
obra más cara de un creador vivo hoy sus
cinco mil archivos contenidos nos atraen
por insustituibles por ser en conjunto
un edificio el acta numérico existe
desde hace décadas pero el sello token
no fungible que liga una obra a un
número de serie en una base de datos ha
explosionado el coleccionismo y la
figura de cripto artistas como la
colombiana gira porque no es lo mismo
tener a la monalisa en jpg que tener el
lienzo de da vinci como tecnología los
non font y bold tokens se basan en
cripto divisas y block change para
certificar que una pieza virtual como el
mensaje del cofundador de twitter es
única cual certificado analógico de
autenticidad
también desde hace años muchos han ido
adjuntando garantías a sus sobres
intangibles sin en efectivo solo que
ahora este mercado tiene galería física
en nueva york' y esta exposición en
beijing con pantallas y proyecciones 300
artistas de los que el 70% no son
creadores digitales materializarán sus
ideas hasta mayo mientras que el
estadounidense en people se rodea en
china tanto de código fuente bitcoin
como de realidad virtual y gibbs en toda
una exploración de la energía
qué fases de trading son intentando
resumir la unef ti es un certificado que
permite saber quién posee una obra de
arte y quién puede venderla es un mundo
que permite regalías a los artistas para
que persistan que permite a los artistas
crear arte y los liga al capitalismo de
una mejor forma que hasta ahora en el
arte art
egipto arte es una manera de enriquecer
los tipos de arte y no de invalidar los
es una nueva experimentación y
exploración
ni en contra ni el favor si recalcamos
los dos rostros de esos toquen
naturalizan una economía falta de agarre
digital es decir pone límites a las
copias y da oportunidades de
monetización a los artistas
si bien rompe con la esencia de la red
libre e incontrolable a la vez que sus
transacciones son nocivas para el medio
ambiente sin duda cuando el artista
sueca charlotte johansson usaba gráficas
en un ordenador apple para crear tapices
no consumía un mes de electricidad de un
ciudadano que se estima en en el chip
precursora en el uso de imágenes
digitales para hacer textiles feministas
y políticos contra guerras y golpes de
estado proponemos indagar en su carrera
anti mercado hoy exhibida en el museo
reina sofía de madrid
asimismo otras el fastuoso desfiló en el
cairo de 22 momias de la realeza
veneradas por tradición y criticadas por
el lavado turístico del presidente up
del fatal sí sí quedó inaugurado el
museo de la civilización egipcia que no
sólo las albergará sino que dará paso a
la próxima apertura del gran museo de
guiza entre estas joyas se conservarán
las reinas y faraones con explicaciones
sobre momificación y un decorado cual
tumba soterrada lo curioso es que a lo
macabro de su visualización se une una
sensación de maldición por su traslado
no descartable luego del bloqueo del
canal de suez el accidente de tren o el
derrumbe de un edificio
lo más importante del museo es el
concepto de civilización no una época un
momento concreto cada exposición cuenta
una historia en torno a la civilización
y las conectamos todas
y la sala que será una verdadera tumba
con inscripciones no sólo contendrá las
momias sino sus antigüedades sarcófagos
y copias de radiografías mostrando si
hay una historia tras la muerte de estas
ahumada
el público del museo el taquillazo que
han generado los efectos y golpes de
godzilla versus con con las mejores
cifras de la crisis cinéfila indican
ganas de cultura y asia ciertas salas
llega villiers con el primer guión en
más de 10 años de neil burger director
del instituto de una tripulación joven
que por no conocer no sabe de evolución
terrícola enfermedad o placer una
claustrofobia similar al actual que
indaga con droga mediante nuestro más
crudo interior
aunque el plan asegurado por maravilla
de película de 2021 es another ground
truck en danés destilada la trama gira
sobre cuatro profesores que además de
amistad comparten un hastío por sus
monótonas vidas y así cual prueba
wilders deciden practicar una teoría que
expone que un nivel de 0,5 gramos de
alcohol en sangre mejoraría nuestra
felicidad y habilidades sólo que la
soledad la incomunicación en una
dinamarca con graves problemas de
alcoholismo es sólo una capa de una
cinta que celebra en la vida y está
rodada entre amigos es así como esta
historia etílica con profundidad en cada
personaje es un retrato más allá de lo
nórdico o la bebida trata quiénes somos
con nuestras versiones
[Música]
y como vimos a entenderlo crypton cierra
más que arte los hay como kings of leon
que lo han hecho disco a gorila su 20
aniversario le está costando críticas
por su festejo en el cine pero ya sea un
méndez y steve aoki están acostumbrados
y ante estos cambios sólo nos quedan
bailar y suspirar por esta vida
cambiante como propone thomas vinterberg
hasta pronto cuídense
[Música]
por ti
con
[Música]
bueno
no verdad
[Música]
no